The first stationary bike was developed by a
London physician in the late 18th century to
exercise the joints of patients suffering
from gout, rheumatic disorders or other
afflictions. The modern stationary bike is
all about helping people stay fit to prevent
illnesses. On this stationary bike, magnets
linked to the flywheel create tension that
causes the cyclist to push harder, making
the workout truly an uphill battle.
Production starts with steel tubing for the
base.
A probe locates the center of the tubing.
This reference point allows a computerized
laser cutter to find the exact spots to cut
assembly holes with the assembly holes cut.
The laser slices the tubing to the correct
length.
An automated system retrieves the part and
transfers it to a holding area.
A worker inserts screws in the base part,
which will attach it to the main frame.
He pipes sealant around the screws.
Another worker now arranges the three
tubular base parts in a welding fixture and
clamps them in place.
The fixture revolves and meets up with a
robotic welder.
The robot welds the three parts together.
This completes the base of the stationary
bike.
The bike's mainframe has been configured on
the other side of the welding fixture.
The robot welds these parts together.
The fixture rotates to serve up another base
assembly to the robot, and the worker
collects the welded mainframe from the
reverse side.
He grinds the welded seams smooth and gets
rid of burrs on the steel.
Workers sandblast the metal, wash it, and
apply primer.
After grounding the mainframe, another
worker sprays electrostatically charged resin
and pigment onto it.
Once it's baked on, this powder coat will
provide a protective finish.
At another station, a 55 ton press punches
holes into posts for the bike's handlebar and
seat. The holes are for adjusting the height
of these parts.
Next up is the casting for mounting the
handlebar to the post.
Using another press, the worker entrenches
the top of the post in the casting.
He taps the casting with a rubber mallet to
tweak the installation and sets the assembly
aside. At another station, a worker arranges
numerous seat posts in tight alignment.
He drapes a stencil of sequential lettering
on top of the posts.
He dips an etching wand in a chemical
solution and then moves it over the letters
five times.
This burns the letters into the steel,
providing markers for height adjustment.
An assembler drives a wedge into one of the
bike's two crank arms to create a hole that
the axle will fit into.
He checks the depth of the hole with a
gauge.
He inserts the end of the axle in the hole
and, using a press, pushes it into place.
He measures the hole from the other side of
the crank arm, and confirms that the axle has
been set to the correct depth.
He then bolts the assembly to a precise
torque.
He locks the crank arm assembly in a lathe.
He slips a foam sleeve over the axle to
protect it from shards of flying metal.
As a tool machines the part of the crank arm
that will ultimately hold the bike's pulley.
Another member of the team now assembles
bearings to a wheel hub.
He slides two bearings with a spacer in a
press.
He heats the hub in an oven, causing the
metal to expand.
The machine presses the hub sandwich
together.
As the hub cools, it shrinks for a tight fit
to the bearings.
He installs a retaining clip in the hub to
also keep it together.
Next up are the holders for the magnets that
create resistance on the flywheel.
A worker places each one in a fixture to
inspect the dimensions.
He then checks the strength of the magnets
in a tester and satisfied.
He inserts two in each holder.
This metal cage pulled into position by the
magnets completes the magnetic field.
Stay tuned for more on the making of this
stationary bike.
The assembler installs the magnetic
resistance unit so that it swings from a
bracket on the main frame.
This bracket also holds the computer board.
He mounts the aluminum flywheel to the axle,
sliding it between the magnets and the
tension device.
He caps the flywheel hub and secures the cap
with screws.
The torsion spring equipped cover completes
the stationary bikes tension system.
He assembles the crank, arm and axle to the
bike and installs a bearing.
Then the bike moves on to the next station.
Another worker places an alignment tool on
the back axle.
He loops an elastic belt with grooves around
the small pulley on the flywheel, and around
the larger crank arm pulley linking the two.
He inserts another tool into the crank arm
and turns it to better wrap the belt around
the large crank pulley.
He then removes both installation tools.
He installs four flat bushings in the
handlebar post.
These bushings make it possible for the
handlebar to be raised and lowered.
He applies a decal with the height
indicators made of a rugged synthetic
material. The decal encases three sides of
the metal post and this protects it from
abrasion. He bolts the second crank arm to
the axle and torques it to the
specified tension.
Next up is the seat assembly.
He slides the seat stem into the post and
tightens the adjustment knob to lock it in
place. He inserts the handlebar post into
the bike frame and fishes the gear, cable and
communication wires through it.
He secures the handlebar post with the
adjustment knob.
He connects the communication line to the
resistance system's computer board.
He links the gear cable to the resistance
system and tests its functionality.
Satisfied, he tightens a nut at the side to
secure the cable.
Another worker installs a plastic cover on
the drive train.
This will protect the cyclist's legs from
the pulley system and shield the metal
components from human sweat.
For added moisture protection, she applies
sealer around a welded reinforcement on the
bike frame. She then encases the fork of the
bike with more molded plastic.
Bolts. Secure the casings to the bike.
She now places a magnetized microphone on
the axle and spins the flywheel at a high
rpm. This is a test.
The bike must operate noiselessly and the
decibel meter confirms the noise level is
negligible. She also feels the frame for
unwanted vibrations.
She now sets the location of the magnetic
resistance mechanism using a special tool.
This calibrates the resistance so that the
handlebar computer can find it and display
the resistance setting during cycling.
Another member of the team then applies
thread locking adhesive to the screw holes in
the crank arms.
He screws the pedals tightly to the crank
arms and torques them to a specific setting.
The worker aligns the four bolt holes on the
frame to the bolts on the base, and secures
them with cap nuts.